Let's talk about the thought process in more detail. The first question I asked
myself was, which nouns in this problem description are doing things? Well, the
manager is getting assignments, and marking them with priorities, and assigning
them to photographers. Photographers are getting the assignments from the
manager, and completing them. Assignments don't seem to do too much, but we
need to keep some information associated with the assignments. In particular, I
thought an assignment would have a priority, and maybe, whether it's finished
or not. They would also have the original description. Perhaps I would even
want to store the finished work in the assignment. So maybe the finished method
would take in an assignment. You might also want customer objects. Maybe the
customers are doing something interesting when they create the assignments or
maybe the manager keeps a list of customers and assigns the priorities based on
who the customer is. Maybe you would want an object to represent a priority. If
you imagine the priorities as just numbers and higher numbers mean higher
priorities then you probably wouldn't need a special priority class. But if you
wanted priorities to age over time, and increase the longer you have the
assignment, then you might want to class your priorities, because they would
have behavior. This kind of design work can be very difficult, because there's
so many ways you might start. But it also becomes a lot of fun as you get
better at it. This process becomes a kind of story telling. You're using the
code to document the relationships between all of the actors in the story. And
creating a model for how to solve the problem.